today federal agents raided the home and
office of President Trump's personal
attorney Michael Cohen is the lawyer who
paid an adult film actress hush money to
keep secret her account of an affair
with mr. Trump stormy Daniels says the
alleged affair happened back in 2006 the
payment was made to her days before the
2016 election Cohen's attorney confirmed
the raids and called them inappropriate
and unnecessary the no-knock raids by
FBI agents were the result of a referral
by Special Counsel Robert Muller to the
US attorney in New York we have Fox team
coverage on this breaking news John
Roberts is at the White House with the
administration reaction we start off
though with chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge here in
the bureau could even Catherine well
thank you very had confirmation late
today from Michael Cohen's attorney that
there were three raids that were
executed on behalf of the US Attorney's
Office in New York City as you mentioned
the law office as well as the family
home and a hotel room where the family
is staying temporarily while some
renovations are happening at their
apartment we also received a statement a
late today from his attorney that reads
in part the decision by the US
Attorney's Office in New York to conduct
their investigation using search
warrants is completely inappropriate and
unnecessary it resulted in the
unnecessary seizure of protected
attorney-client communications also late
today we received a statement from
stormy Daniels attorney Michael a
vanetti and it reads in part is I
predicted last week on CNN and MSNBC mr.
Cohen has been placed in the crosshairs
by mr. Trump he has been set up to take
the fall an enormous amount of misplaced
faith has been placed on his shoulders
and I do not believe he has the metal to
withstand it if I am correct this could
end very badly for mr. Trump as well as
others also late today we spoke with a
source close to the president legal team
who described the race to us as a big
deal very aggressive and an effort by
the special counsel of Robert Miller's
office to put the squeeze on the
president saying the likelihood now of
an interview session a
question-and-answer session between the
president and mr. Muller he said is at
least very remote for the time being
Brett Catherine quickly it seems like
there are a couple of things that
potentially are happening here
one that they found something that is
leading them in this Russia
investigation to some money tie or
something
that's all in Muller's investigation but
two that he found something else and is
passing it on to the US attorney in
Manhattan if you look at the the law the
statute if you determine that additional
jurisdiction is necessary in order to
fully investigate and resolve matters
that assigned or investigate new matters
that come to light in the course of your
investigation you should follow the
procedures set forth that could be a
possibility - like passing it all right
you're right on top of the central point
Bret it's whether this is ultimately
gigged in a remain part of the Special
Counsel investigation and there is some
kind of tied to Russia and Robert Muller
has received the authorities or extended
authorities from the Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein to pursue this
line of investigation or whether he's
uncovered evidence he believes as part
of a separate criminal matter which will
be pursued by the US Attorney's Office
but the other big headline today is
according to Michael Cohen's attorney
they took attorney-client privileged
information and you have to have a clean
team go through that evidence you can
either have a judge or FBI agents but I
was told there's a high level of
distrust because Cohen was already
cooperating and to have the FBI come in
might be just a bridge too far for the
Trump legal team Bret well let's hear
from the Trump administration what
they're saying at this hour joining us
from the North Lawn chief White House
correspondent John Roberts with the
breaking news could even jump Bret good
evening to you the White House itself
not saying a whole lot about these
developments other than the president
has been watching the news very closely
but sources close to the investigation
are telling Fox News a whole lot first
of all they have no clue what this is
all about they know that the FBI sees
tax records from Michael Cohen at his
home his office in his hotel room they
don't know if that means that this is
related to some sort of real estate
transaction remember Cohen was trying to
put together a big deal in Moscow one
that he says fell apart not long after
he tried to put it together there was
also the fact that these records related
to the stormy Daniels payment were
seized was this part of an FEC
investigation that the US attorney
referred to the
that rather the special counsel referred
to the US attorney for the Southern
District of New York who then got the
FBI involved but there is a sense here
that refer to my notes here that this
investigation by Robert Muller is out of
control that they believe that this
rating of Michael Cohen's office and the
seizing of documents that were
confidential and were subject to
attorney-client privilege as a quote
demonstration of bad faith and they say
that it underscores the importance that
the president not give an interview to
Robert Muller so this could be a big
change here the president's outside
legal team was looking at narrowly
defining a set of parameters for the
president to sit down with Robert Muller
now it looks as though that may be going
away according to one source that I
talked with Brett they said what in the
name of God is Muller doing and then
there was a belief here that Muller may
be trying to take down the president so
while we're not hearing a lot from the
White House we are hearing from people
who are familiar with this investigation
that they think that Muller crossed a
very big line today and that as a result
of that the president should not sit
down with him Brett okay John stand by
who